what's the deal with white people the
owner of rubbing butts barbecue wants
you to know that at his restaurant jun
11th is white appreciation day the catch
the owner of the restaurant is hispanic
the owner said we have a whole month for
Black History Month we have a whole
month for hispanic heritage month so we
thought the least you could do was offer
one data appreciate white Americans with
more than eighty percent of the town's
residents being white customers could be
lining up around the block to get their
discounted pulled pork and brisket the
owner promise is that this is not a joke
having been a victim of racism before in
his own life he hopes the attention will
start a productive discussion about race
okay so the reason I thought this was
interesting was because when I first saw
this on the internet and on Twitter
everybody was going crazy wyd
appreciation day like it was some sort
of KKK of N or some sort of white
supremacist event right but of course it
turns out that the guy basically this is
sort of a joke and he's just saying look
black people have their monthly t know
people have their mother white but we're
going to give him a couple hours no big
deal but the outrage of machine just
gets going well you saw the headlines on
this would you first think well that's
the thing people on the internet only
read the headlines so they see it they
get outraged but I think it's actually
kind of a like a funny cute initiative I
mean you could tell that the guy has a
sense of humor from the name of the
restaurant alone yeah Robin but right
that kind of gave it away from me that
if it was in fact some kind of like
older white racist dude that he would be
awfully ironic yeah if it had been an
older white racist dude would it have
still been okay if he just wanted to do
that and the privacy of his own
restaurant I know we're all over
everybody for baking gay cakes and
flowers and but but would that have been
okay probably not especially like right
in the heels of Baltimore going on at
Ferguson I don't know if it's ever a
good time but certainly not now would be
a good time yeah and what's the point of
these days anyway these appreciation
days are to celebrate minorities right
and with with whites not being a
minority what's the point of doing that
in the first place yeah so what do you
make of that because we do have a lot of
that and the
right now I feel like there's this
feeling that white people feel like
they're under attack which seems to be
the reverse of what's actually going on
but in another way it seems like a human
reaction to what that changing times or
something what do we do about white
people like you do hear this all the
time that they that there's a lot of
people that feel like Oh everything's
changing well things weren't so great
for minorities in the 50s so yeah she
changes yeah no I mean I think it's
definitely a time where you know our
sort of our sensitivity radars need to
be you know primed and you know in sort
of you know full operation but um but
this story I just feel like is it's
benign is there some legitimacy to sort
of white people feeling like things are
changing too fast or anything like that
absolutely not I mean come on the more
multicultural we get the faster the
better and I think this is clearly a PR
stunt I think it's working really well
for the guy here yeah over the place a
good for him but uh let's not have a
wide appreciation day anytime soon yeah
what do you guys think about just the
general state of race which we talk
about a lot on the show we did a story
last week that you know right now in the
country most polls show that white
people on black people feel almost polar
opposite about the state of race
relations it seems to me it's obviously
a lot better than it was 50 years ago
but it seems like we've had this like
sudden slide backwards or is that a
media constructor what do you think I
think that you know obviously we live in
a heated time for sure with you know
what's going on in the news but um but I
think these are conversations that need
to be had and so you know it's important
to recognize our you know the white
privilege that that I think we havin to
go with full sensitivity to recognize
why minorities you know would feel so
outraged yeah that doesn't mean you're
giving up any of your white rights right
exactly yeah you're gonna be okay as
white what do you think about the
general state of race in America right
now it's closed it's shocking it sort of
it comes in waves right we had the
Rodney King in the 90s and now we're
sort of back to that place where
everything is kicking off and is all of
the stuff's going down and I don't know
why that happens like that it kind of
surges and then it goes away maybe the
media feeds a lot of that too you know
but we could look we clearly have a
problem I mean a lot of these right
answer being instigated by police
brutality which is clearly out of
control so we need to deal with those
issues and once we fix those hopefully
we can all get back to being friends
again well said there's a fitting ending
for this one alright white appreciated a
by a latino owner at a restaurant for a
couple hours what do you think let us
know in the comments right